ein titan de lüfte der in einem
ukrainischen hangar vor sich hin rostet
man sieht die tragflächen den riesigen
rumpf alles an diesem flugzeug ist
gigantisch
ein geisterhaftes areal in indiana mit
seltsamen gebäuden
an den häusern sind rutschen aber sie
dienen nicht dem vergnügen
verwitterte türme in griechenland mit
legendäre vergangenheit
ein dramatischer anblick
die ruinen der türme hoch oben auf dem
hügel im hintergrund das meer
und überreste strategisch angeordneter
bauten an schottlands küste
der ort ist so friedlich
aber diese betonbauten erzählen von
einer anderen einer dramatischen zeit
[Musik]
zerfallen bebauten
ruinen aus vergangener zeit
einst mühsam erschaffen heute nur noch
schatten ihrer selbst
seit ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
[Musik]
am rande der ukrainischen hauptstadt
kiew steht eine unscheinbare anlage die
ein geheimnis birgt
[Musik]
wir befinden uns in einem industrie vor
ort
auf dem verfallenen areal spießt gras
aus dem asphalt
aber dann sieht man dieses riesige
gebäude
das erste was einem auffällt sind die
gewaltigen tore mehr als 30 meter hoch
was auch immer da drin ist es muss
ungeheuer groß sein
wenn man etwas ungewöhnliches sieht dass
die erwartungen sprengt zieht einen das
an man will wissen was sich hinter
diesen türen befindet
im inneren alte industrieanlagen die
erahnen lassen was hier gebaut wurde
das ganze wirkt wie eine gruft für
historische flugzeuge
man sieht überwiegend einzelteile die
nie zusammen gebaut wurden
prof der chor ein riesenhafter
flugzeugrumpf überragt den rest
[Musik]
er ist gigantisch er thront regelrecht
über allem und füllt einen großteil der
halle
es ist offensichtlich dass dieser
flugzeug gigant eine verbindung zum
kalten krieg hat aber welche genau das
ist die geschichte dahinter warum ist
der bau so weit fortgeschritten ohne
dass man ihn zu ende gebracht hat
[Musik]
in diesem mächtigen hangar befindet sich
ein echtes stück luftfahrtgeschichte er
spielt eine zentrale rolle im wettstreit
zweier supermächte
genau diese janko hat fast 40 jahre lang
im entwicklungsteam des
flugzeugherstellers antonow gearbeitet
auch diese maschine hat er mit geplant
[Musik]
der ort an dem wir hier stehen ist eine
lagerhalle unseres unternehmens
hier werden unsere maschinen und
bauteile aufbewahrt
antonow ist ein ukrainisches
luftfahrtunternehmen
es ist bekannt für den bau besonders
großer maschinen das ist ihr
markenzeichen
die dimensionen der maschine sind
wichtig um ihre geschichte zu verstehen
mit 84 metern ist der rumpf elf meter
länger als der des größten heutigen
passagierflugzeugs
nicht einmal der berühmte riesen airbus
a380 ist so lang
dieses flugzeug wurde eindeutig für
einen besonderen zweck konstruiert es
soll etwas sehr großes und schweres
transportieren
die hauptaufgabe des flugzeugs ist die
beförderung von frachten mit enormen
gewicht seine nutzlast beträgt
250 tonnen
konzipiert während des kalten krieges
soll dieser fliegenden festung eine
besondere rolle zukommen
beim kalten krieg denkt man automatisch
an mögliche militärische
auseinandersetzungen zwischen usa und
udssr an atomwaffen und nuklearpotenzial
aber der kalte krieg spielte sich auch
auf vielen anderen ebenen ab
es ging auch darum auf dem propaganda
schlachtfeld die nase vorn zu haben und
der schauplatz dafür war das weltall das
space race katapultierte technik und
erfindergeist in eine neue dimension
[Musik]
1972 riefen die usa das space shuttle
programm ins leben für die udssr war das
ein alarmsignal denn es war ein riesiger
sprung beim wettlauf ins all die
amerikaner verfügten über eine neue
technologie und die russen nicht die
sowjets lagen zurück aber sie wussten
dass im spaceshuttle die zukunft lag
deshalb gibt es dieses flugzeug
dies ist die antonow an-22 5 das größte
flugzeug der welt
doch welche rolle spielt dieser goliath
der lüfte bei der sowjetischen eroberung
des alls
als die usa ihr shuttle-programm
bekanntgaben beschlossen die sowjets ein
eigenes programm aufzulegen genannt
buran schneesturm
die udssr war geografisch ein schier
endloser raum mit vielen exzellenten
technologie standorten für ein
raumfahrtprogramm braucht man riesige
teile und komponenten
das ist xxl technologie und um die
startklar zu bekommen muss man alle
diese teile irgendwie an einen ort
schaffen
also entwickelten die sowjets den plan
eine raumfähre zum kosmodrom nach süd
kasachstan zu fliegen aber es gab kein
flugzeug das groß genug war um eine
raumfähre zu transportieren
den ingenieuren war klar dass der bau
eines flugzeugs dass solche probleme
lösen könnte die industrie entscheidend
voranbringen würde
[Musik]
das galt nicht nur für die sowjetunion
sondern für die ganze welt
die antonov ingenieure nehmen die
herausforderung an
nach ihrem erstflug
1988 startet die a n225 im jahr darauf
mit der bahn raumfähre auf ihrem rücken
ein hauptproblem beim huckepack nehmen
eines shuttles ist dass der luftstrom
unterbrochen wird bei der konstruktion
der antonow an-22 5 hat man daher das
heck in zwei teile geteilt sodass die
vertikalen stabilisatoren sich außerhalb
der turbulenzen befindet
als das flugzeug dann tatsächlich abhob
war das eine überraschung für die ganze
welt und auch für uns selbst so ein
flugzeug in der luft zu sehen ist schon
fantastisch
1989 wurde die aa n225 bei der pariser
flugschau der welt präsentiert das war
ein technologischer durchbruch und jeder
der die maschine sah war einfach
überwältigt von den schieren ausmaße
dieses flugzeugs
[Musik]
der durchschlagende erfolg der an-22
fünf ermutigt die sowjets drei weitere
maschinen zu planen
dieses flugzeug hier sollte nummer zwei
in der produktionslinie sein
[Musik]
abgesehen von der technischen leistungen
gelang den sowjets damit ein riesiger
propaganda erfolg
auch wenn wir am ende ein bisschen zu
spät kam
ein sturm braut sich über den größten
flugzeug der welt zusammen
topless in diesen jahren zerfiel die
sowjetunion alles änderte sich
es gab keine verwendung für das flugzeug
es wurde eingemottet und die weiteren
modelle wurden nie fertiggestellt
[Musik]
ohne den wettlauf ins all und den
wettbewerb mit den usa wozu brauchte die
welt ein flugzeug dieser größe
darauf hatte niemand eine antwort
[Musik]
doch die geschichte des riesenfliegers
ist noch nicht vorbei
der pilot dimitri antonov ist einer der
wenigen die das flugzeug fliegen durften
2001 wurde die 1 225 wieder zum leben
erweckt inzwischen wird sie vor allem
für humanitäre missionen und
medizinische hilfslieferungen genutzt
angesichts des preises von 27.000 euro
pro flugstunde wird sie nur selten
gebucht wenn sie jedoch abhebt ist ihr
alle aufmerksamkeit sicher
[Musik]
als wir zum beispiel in australien
landeten wurden wir dort von mehr als
15.000 leuten erwartet wenn man begreift
dass die alle gekommen sind um uns und
das flugzeug zu sehen ist das toll wir
sind stolz diese maschine zu fliegen
allein wegen ihrer zahlreichen
weltrekorde muss man sie gesehen haben
sie hat die schwerste kommerzielle
fracht der welt befördert und auch das
schwerste einzelobjekt der welt
[Musik]
bis heute bleibt dieses faszinierende
kapitel der luftfahrtgeschichte
unvollendet doch eines tages erhebt sich
vielleicht auch die zweite antonow in
die lüfte
[Musik]
anders als das erste flugzeug wurde
diese maschine nie fertiggestellt
trotzdem sind wir sehr stolz auf sie
natürlich wollen wir sie zu ende bauen
wir haben auch die mittel dazu alles was
wir brauchen ist ein kunde der sie
kaufen will dann würden wir sofort mit
der arbeit beginnen
staaten wie china werfen einen blick auf
die antonov denn sie könnte beim
wettlauf ins all hilfreich sein ihre
beste zeit könnte immer noch kommen
[Musik]
an der einsamen nordküste schottlands
erhebt sich eine ansammlung von ruinen
über den schroffen klippen
am rande der nordwestlichen highlands an
der spitze schottlands ist man der
gewalt des nordatlantiks vollkommen
ausgeliefert nur wenn man sich
und zerklüftet und zwischen den felsen
ragen beton festungen hervor
[Musik]
es handelt sich eindeutig um eine
verteidigungsanlage
einige sehen aus wie beobachtungsposten
andere eher wie bunker oder geschützt
stellungen der ort wurde offensichtlich
für eine große militärische operation
genutzt
man fragt sich warum dieser verschlafene
landstrich so vehement verteidigt werden
musste
dieser ort war einst der schauplatz
einer gewagten operation noch heute
wirkt er irgendwie geheimnisvoll
der krieg hat hier seine spuren
hinterlassen und weil das alles
verschlusssache war ist noch immer
vieles unklar
die geschichte dieser bemerkenswerten
städte erzählt vom durchhaltewillen und
opferbereitschaft
diese bewährten beton stellungen stammen
zweifellos aus der ersten hälfte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
genauer gesagt aus der zeit des zweiten
weltkriegs
und wenn wir an diese jahre auf den
britischen inseln denken geht es meist
darum london gegen eine deutsche
invasion zu schützen
wir glaubten die alliierten das hitler
von norden aus angreifen würde oder gibt
es noch einen anderen grund diese
entlegene gegend auf den britischen
inseln so stark zu befestigen
dieser teil schottlands ist
nazi-deutschland geografisch nicht
zugewandt aber warum errichtet man
wehranlagen die der bedrohung abgewandt
sind
[Musik]
die gegend ist nur spärlich besiedelt
doch für nicola kirk geht von dieser
militäranlage seit jeher ein großer reiz
aus
als kind habe ich zwischen diesen
bunkern gespielt alte rostige
betonbauten ein toller
abenteuerspielplatz
einst herrschte an diesem ort reges
treiben
wir sind eine kleine gemeinde die von
der fischverarbeitung lebt doch
plötzlich landeten hier 3000 soldaten
sie kamen von überall her aus indien
polen großbritannien und aus anderen
überseeregionen
doch warum strömen truppen aus aller
herren länder in wiese verlassene gegend
relikte von militärgerät liefern die
antwort frances rasse erforscht die
anlage seit jahrzehnten
das ist eine stellung führen 152 mm
geschützt von ihnen gab es hier zwei
sondern auch zwei weitere ein stück
weiter sie dienten zur abschreckung und
sahen bedrohlich aus
unterhalb der geschütze an der
küstenlinie verlief ein minenfeld
und dahinter eine weitere
verteidigungslinie
es gab anti um botnetze im prinzip
großmaschinen ratsch laufen ähnlich wie
bei einem kettenhemd die hingen zwischen
schwimmkörpern an der oberfläche und
beton teilen auf dem meeresboden
beobachtungstürme bieten schutz gegen u
boote und angriffe aus der luft oder vom
meer
es ist nur schwer vorstellbar was dort
früher los war
hunderte schiffe und tausende soldaten
tummelten sich auf engstem raum
dies ist blocher eine meeresbucht die im
zweiten weltkrieg als geheimer truppen
sammelpunkt genutzt wird er wird ins
leben gerufen als die deutsche wehrmacht
den russlandfeldzug startet
als die deutschen russland im juni 1941
angriffen stießen sie sehr schnell fast
bis nach moskau vor als erstes trat
großbritannien in den krieg ein später
auch die usa die russland ihre
unterstützung zusagten
[Musik]
kriegswichtige nachschub muss von einer
geeigneten basis auf dem seeweg nach
russland transportiert werden ohne dass
irgendjemand wenn davon bekommt
[Musik]
viele leute fragen warum gerade loch you
die antwort darauf ist denkbar einfach
weil es für die deutschen bombe anfang
des krieges extrem weit weg waren die
einfahrt ist sehr eng und dadurch
leichter zu verteidigen das wasser bis
zu 75 meter tief es ist weitläufig und
ein sicherer ankerplatz
[Musik]
besonders die meeresbucht ist sehen sie
liegt im salzwasser und ist den
elementen ausgesetzt
zugleich ist es der perfekte ort um eine
groß angelegte marine operation im
geheimen vorzubereiten bis man dann
plötzlich loslegt
im februar 1942 ist die basis loch jo
voll einsatzfähig noch im selben monat
begeben sich die ersten nordmeer geleit
züge auf die reise
handelsschiffe transportieren die
benötigten kriegs güter während
britische kanadische und us schiffe den
konvois geleitschutz bieten
die nordmeer geleit züge gehörten zu den
grössten konzentrierten aktionen während
des krieges 14 länder nahmen daran teil
von indien über panama holland
großbritannien kanada die usa und viele
mehr aus allen orten der welt wurden
soldaten zusammengezogen auf schiffe
gesetzt und nach loch you gebracht
viele soldaten haben keine ahnung wohin
ihre reise geht aber alle haben angst
vor der fahrt ins gefürchtete nordmeer
der erste hinweis dass sg norden ging
und nicht zurück in den süden war die
tatsache dass die schiffe mit ausrüstung
für kaltes wetter beladen wurden zb mit
einem robusten mantel der schütze aber
kaum gegen schnee hagel und eiskalte
welt
die schiffsroute nach russland ist
heimtückisch
die beste schnellste und effektivste
route um kriegsmaterial nach russland zu
bekommen war über die eisfreien hafen im
norden das heißt murmansk und
archangelsk und da führte die nördliche
route hin
die manz gruppe war gefürchtet denn man
muss sie mit angriffen deutscher u-boote
zerstörer und schlachtschiffe rechnen
die von norwegen aus operierten zudem
war die luftwaffe in norwegen
stationiert
[Musik]
hinzu kommen die gefährliche fahrt über
das eiskalte nordmeer nebel in dem sich
eisberge verbargen schneestürme die über
den schiffsboden
viele von ihnen waren jungs oft
freiwillige zum teil erst 16 jahre alt
seeleute die sich nicht zum kriegsdienst
gemeldet hatten kämpften plötzlich gegen
eisstürme und einen allgegenwärtigen
feind können sie die sowjetunion gegen
die grösste land invasion in der
geschichte der menschheit mit waffen
unterstützen und wird love you den nazis
verborgen bleiben
[Musik]
alle schiffe die in loch yuan kamen
wurden zuerst von einem boot überprüft
dann passierten sie die eu bot netze und
erst dann wurde ihnen ein ankerplatz
zugewiesen
hat man brauchte viele unterkünfte für
die seeleute und die hafenarbeiter die
für das betanken beladen und reparieren
der schiffe zuständig waren
[Musik]
doch das a und o ist es unter dem radar
der wehrmacht zu bleiben
man musste möglichst funkstille haben
denn der feind verfügte über teilanlagen
daher brauchte man gut sichtbare signal
posten damit man über lichtsignale oder
signalflaggen innerhalb der flotte
kommunizieren konnte und eben nicht über
funk
die beste verteidigung ist die
geheimhaltung
insgesamt 19 konvois mit 481
frachtschiffen und 100 begleitschiffen
verlassen noch während des zweiten
weltkriegs in richtung ausland
ihre vorgehensweise ist hocheffektiv
das erstaunliche ist dass trotz
zahlreicher deutscher angriffe in
nordrussland nur sieben prozent der
schiffe in den konvois verloren gingen
die umfangreichen material und
waffenlieferungen nach russland tragen
dazu bei dass dies auf jetzt hitlers
riesige invasionstruppen letztlich
zurückschlagen können
die stiefel der russischen soldaten
kamen aus amerika
die geländewagen die durch russland
fuhren kamen aus amerika
weil die alliierten so viele güter in
die sowjetunion brachten waren die
sowjets in der lage weiter zu kämpfen
und ohne den sieg der roten armee im
osten hätte man deutschland letztlich
nicht besiegen können
[Musik]
nachdem april 1945 wurde loriot ein
sammelbecken für deutsche u-boote die
sich auf see ergeben hatten
doch der erfolg hat einen hohen preis
3000 mutige junge männer machten sich
auf den weg nach norden und starben bei
der wie winston churchill es nannte
schlimmsten reise der welt
[Musik]
doch wie um ist ein monument für die
zusammenarbeit der nation russen
amerikaner briten und kanadier alle
kamen zusammen um nazi deutschland zu
besiegen
heute sorgt ein museum dafür dass dieses
kapitel der geschichte nicht vergessen
wird ebenso wie die beton ruinen auf den
klippen
sie müssen erhalten bleiben damit die
menschen begreifen welche opfer hier
gebracht worden
[Musik]
im norden des us-bundesstaates indiana
liegt eine ansammlung überwucherte
bauten die ein explosives geheimnis
verbergen
das gesamte gelände ist tausende hektar
groß
man sieht cluster von gebäuden die weit
auseinander liegen
einige von ihnen sind von gestrüpp und
bäumen überwuchert andere sehen fast aus
wie baumhäuser
wenn man länger herankommt sieht man
dass einige gebäude seltsam unterteilt
und die einzelnen segmente durch dicke
mauern begrenzt sind
dieser ort sieht aus als hätte man ihn
komplett vergessen
als wenn etwas furchtbares passiert wäre
dass die leute davon abhält hierher zu
kommen
ihre dimensionen lassen vermuten dass
diese anlage einst von großer bedeutung
war die ungewöhnliche anordnung der
gebäude liefert einen hinweis auf ihren
gefährlichen zweck
wenn man sich die anlage ansieht wird
klar dass es hier nicht um effizienz
ging
sondern um sicherheit
was könnte so wichtig und gleichzeitig
so gefährlich sein
heute holt sich die natur den ort zurück
doch einst strömten arbeiter hin diese
gebäude zu ihnen gehörte ferner die
schulz die hier in den 50er jahren
arbeitete ein großteil ihrer arbeit war
streng vertraulich
[Musik]
die devise war was man hier sieht und
hört bleibt auch hier wir durften
draußen kein wort über das verlieren was
wir hier sagen
dass diese anlage im ländlichen indianer
gebaut wird ist kein zufall
doch geheimhaltung ist nicht der einzige
grund dafür
[Musik]
wenn man eine fabrik für geländewagen
bauen will geht man nach detroit dann
dort gibt es die arbeitskräfte und die
anlagen die man braucht wenn man dinge
produziert die in die luft fliegen
können dann macht man das nicht mitten
in der stadt
versteckt im wald finden sich weitere
hinweise
überall sind notrutschen installiert die
wurden nicht zum spaß gebaut denn das
hier ist kein spielplatz
die rutschen waren als sicherheit für
die angestellten gedacht falls es mal
knallte
dies ist die kingsbury ordnance plant
eine riesige munitionsfabrik
am sinken dezember 1941 greifen die
japaner die us marinebasis in pearl
harbor kurz darauf treten die usa in den
krieg ein
fabriken wie die in kingsbury werden
dringend benötigt doch eine solche
anlage zu bauen dauert monate wenn nicht
jahre im
krieg in europa und dem pazifik zu
führen brauchte man munition
die us regierung entscheidet sich für
einen ort in indianer der direkt an der
bahn
zudem ist er in der nähe der großen
kohle und stahlproduktion im mittleren
westen die pittsburgh
die anlage erstreckt sich über gut 50
quadratkilometer sie ist riesig
die fabrikgebäude liegen weit
auseinander
wäre es in einem bereich zu einer
explosion gekommen hätte so keine
kettenreaktion mit den anderen gegeben
auf dem gelände befinden sich auch
munitionsdepots labore büros und
testanlagen verbunden sind sie durch
viele kilometer an bahnschienen fern
erinnert sich an ihre dienstzeit dort
ende der 50er jahre das system
funktionierte da nicht anders als
während des krieges
wir arbeiteten an band 1 und stellten
dort die zünder und die booster her die
braucht man um die munition zu zünden
und die explosion der granate auszulösen
an zwei entstanden 20 mm granaten
anbahnt 330 mm granaten und so ging es
weiter bis zur band 5
die trennung der produktionslinien ist
nicht die einzige sicherheitsmaßnahme
auch das endprodukt selbst beeinflusst
die bauweise der gebäude
sie produzierten vor allem rauch armes
pulver dazu braucht man viele
verschiedene säuren was den prozess sehr
gefährlich machte
die innenwände sind massiv gebaut die
außenmauern und dächer wiederum sind
eher in leichtbauweise hergestellt aus
wellblech glas und plastik sollte es zu
einem unfall kommen sind die innenwände
so stark dass die explosion sich ihren
weg durch die schwächeren bauteile sucht
und die teuren maschinen und die
arbeitskräfte verschont
angesichts der kriege im pazifik und in
europa muss die riesige fabrik schnell
fertig werden nur wie
im dezember 1941 tritt die usa in den
zweiten weltkrieg ein zwar ist der
überfall auf teilhabe einen
überraschungsangriff doch im hintergrund
hat das militär schon länger
kriegsvorbereitungen getroffen und dafür
gesorgt dass rüstungsfabrik medien
kingsbury einsatzbereit sind
die geschichte war schon in vollem gange
als die amerikaner nach pearl harbor in
den krieg zogen sie wollten sich
eigentlich nicht in den krieg
hineinziehen lassen sahen aber die
gefahr eines möglichen deutschen sieges
und begannen massiv aufzurüsten
schon im sommer 1941 gelangt munition
von hier nach europa um die alliierten
zu unterstützen und kingsbury wird immer
wichtiger die waffenfabrik in teams
bolivar von entscheidender bedeutung für
die us kriegsmaschinerie während des
zweiten weltkriegs
zu hochzeiten produziert kingsbury jeden
tag
180.000 aufschlagzünder mehr als 46.000
40 millimeter granaten und 500.000
schuss 20 millimeter munition
um diesen gewaltigen ausstoß zu
bewältigen braucht es viele hände doch
die sind im ländlichen indianer nur
schwer zu finden
sie errichteten eigens eine neue stadt
cayes wird heitz um die vielen neuen
leute unterzubringen
fast 21.000 beschäftigte arbeiten in der
fabrik darunter viele frauen die damit
soziale konventionen brechen und ihren
teil zu den kriegs anstrengungen
beitragen
sie arbeiten volle schichten in den
fabriken manchmal doppelschichten und
damit verändern sie nicht nur das
gesellschaftliche frauenbild sondern
auch das bild das sie selbst von sich
haben
doch dieser gesellschaftliche
fortschritt geht mitgefahren einher und
chronischen erkrankungen
sie waren dort giftigen chemikalien
ausgesetzt sie zogen sich
brandverletzungen zu und wir sind in
einigen fällen besorgniserregende
symptome auf
sie mussten schutzanzüge tragen sie
mussten schmuck ablegen und alles was
statische elektrizität erzeugen konnte
jede art von reibung durch die funken
entstehen hätte eine explosion auslösen
können
im pulver bereich verfärbte eine
chemikalie wenn man mit ihren berührung
kam haut und haare orange
[Musik]
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg bleibt die
fabrik im standby modus
während des koreakriegs wird sie wieder
hochgefahren bis sie 1960 für immer
schließt
[Musik]
heute liegt das areal verlassen da doch
in einer entscheidenden zeit
einen wichtigen beitrag zur verteidigung
amerikas geleistet
ich glaube alle die erarbeiteten hatten
das gefühl ihren teil in diesem krieg
beizutragen
wir waren alle stolz darauf die freiheit
unseres landes zu verteidigen
[Musik]
in einem einsamen landstrich im süden
griechenlands ragt eine zerklüftete
landzunge ins mittelmeer
die gegend ist unwirtlich und selbst
heute verirren sich nur wenige touristen
so weit nach süden
am ende dieser dramatischen halbinsel
die fast einer bergigen wüste erhascht
man den ersten blick auf diese ruinen
[Musik]
von dort hat man einen perfekten
überblick über das meer und die küsten
die firma scheinen eher militärischer
als ziviler natur zu sein
wenden sie verschmelzen mit der
landschaft zugleich wirken sie stolz und
wehrhaft man soll sie bewundern
die bauten sind untrennbar mit den mann
hughton verbunden einem krieger volk das
in griechenland noch heute verehrt wird
zum geheimnis dieser gegend gehört die
frage wer diese kriegerischen man juden
waren und woher es kam
einige glauben dass sie von den
spartanern abstammen und daher diesen
mythos der unbesiegbarkeit in der
griechischen kultur haben
über die jahrhunderte haben die manie
otn sich den ruf von gnadenlosen
kriegern r worden
wie haben sie diesen ruf erlangt und was
haben die verfallenen türme mit dieser
geschichte zu tun
[Musik]
der fremdenführer und autor matthew den
beschäftigt sich seit über 30 jahren mit
diesen festungsartigen worten
wenn man an diesem turm ruinen entlang
läuft stellt man sich vor wie es hier
vor 100 oder 200 jahren aussah das ist
ein ort für leute mit vorstellungskraft
die nicht nur das sehen was jetzt da ist
wenn wir uns also die türme ansehen
fällt einem sofort auf wie hoch sie sind
drei oder vier stockwerke warum zur
verteidigung von dort oben hat man einen
guten überblick über das meer und die
potenziellen bedrohungen von dort
die türme sind sehr eng sie haben
winzige fenster es gibt schützen stände
und platz für waffen
[Musik]
beim bau der gefechts türme wurden
unterschiedliche ziele verfolgt einige
waren rein militärischer natur und
wurden nur in kriegszeiten genutzt
andere offenere bereiche wurden in
friedenszeiten als wohnräume genutzt
wenn es gefährlich wurde zog man sich so
lange wie nötig in den turm zurück
im 15 jahrhundert fliehen die griechen
aus der region um später vor den osmanen
und erreichen die abgelegene money
halbinsel
bald sind sie als man noten berüchtigt
später entfachen sie eine revolution
doch zunächst geht es ums nackte
überleben
das hauptaugenmerk galt der sicherheit
man fürchtete sich vor fremden eroberern
die vom meer kamen wie venezianer oder
türken
aber auch die eigenen nachbarn waren in
dieser unfruchtbaren und rohstoffarmen
gegend eine bedrohung man musste
buchstäblich seinen nachbarn bekämpfen
um zu überleben
blutige fehden zwischen familien haben
hier tradition
sie können monate oder sogar jahre
andauern
das fehde wesen war ein normaler
bestandteil des lebens für die man noten
ein englischer oberst notierte 1805 das
über einen zeitraum von 40 jahren etwa
100 minuten bei einer solchen fehde
getötet worden
löser hand wenn man von 300 einwohnern
100 man verliert ist das eine kolossale
zahl und man erahnt wie erbittert die
fäden in dieser region geführt wurden
jeder klar muss sein grundstück gegen
viele feinde verteidigen seines türken
venezianer piraten oder clans aus der
nachbarschaft und die bevorzugte methode
ist der bau eines turms
[Musik]
dies sind die wehrtürme von mafia
sie sind von entscheidender bedeutung
bei der verteidigung gegen feinde
diese steinernen wolkenkratzer
verschaffen einem einen guten überblick
über potenzielle aggressoren am horizont
sie sind auch eine gute verteidigung
gegen potenzielle angreifer am boden
kleine fenster aus denen man den feind
am boden gut beschießen kann vor allem
wenn man sie blockiert und nur ein
kleines loch für musketen lässt auch
kleine türen sind schwieriger zu
durchbrechen
im späten 18ten jahrhundert als die
bedrohung durch die türken steigt nimmt
die bautätigkeit zu die man noten wehren
sich erbittert gegen die osmanischen
türken die jetzt den rest griechenlands
besetzen
die kämpfe zwischen den türken und in
meine noten wurden erbittert geführt
wenn ein mann judt im kampf verletzt zu
boden ging kam ein soldat küsste ihn auf
die stirn und schlug ihm den kopf ab es
war besser durch die hand eines
kameraden zu sterben als den türken in
die hände zu fallen
im frühen neunzehnten jahrhundert kehrt
die revolution es ist die zeit in der
die man noten ihren ruf als tapfere
krieger zementieren
[Musik]
der unabhängigkeitskrieg begann in der
manie bedeutende clan-chef sammelten
hier ihre truppen und führten sie mit
denen anderer clans zusammen und
gemeinsam verbanden sie sich mit colo
colos den die griechen als den vater der
revolution ansehen
in ganz griechenland hörte man den
slogan freiheit oder tod
die magnetische version war leicht
abgewandelt sie lautete sieg oder tod
das beschreibt die besonderheit der mann
noten sie betrachteten sich immer als
frei und unabhängig und beugten sich
niemals der osmanischen herrschaft
1826 greifen die osmanen erneut die
halbinsel an doch die 7000 soldaten
werden von den kämpfern auf den türmen
zum rückzug gezwungen
1830 erlangt griechenland die
unabhängigkeit der heldenhafte
widerstand der mann noten ist bis heute
nicht vergessen
[Musik]
dies ist der einzige teil griechenlands
der nie an die türken und das osmanische
reich viel
der stolz der griechen auf diese region
rührt von ihrer entschlossenheit nicht
vom osmanischen reich erobert zu werden
der rest griechenlands inklusive kreta
viel an die osmanen aber die manie blieb
unabhängig
die man juden wohnten seit hunderten von
jahren in türmen und änderten deren
bauweise
anfangs waren sie sehr klein und
militärisch organisiert ein weithin
sichtbares zeichen der stärke doch mit
der zeit wurden sie immer wohnlicher
behielten aber ihre struktur und ihre
macht
[Musik]
doch mit der zeit wandern die bewohner
in größere städte ab ziehen in andere
europäische länder nach australien oder
in die usa
die tatsache dass es bei diesen firmen
um krieg und verteidigung ging führte
dazu dass sie in unserer heutigen welt
nicht mehr gebraucht werden also bleiben
sie verrammelt und bröckeln vor sich hin
[Musik]
es ist wichtig dass die türme von batya
erhalten bleiben sie sind zeugen einer
vergangenheit in der das leben schwierig
und von gewalt geprägt
selbst unter diesen schwierigen
bedingungen verspürten die menschen
stolz und empfanden es als privileg ein
mitglied dieser gesellschaft zu sein
[Musik]
heute sind viele der bauten vergessen
und verlassen manche ruinen erinnern an
dunkle zeiten andere waren einst
leuchtende beispiele für technologischen
fortschritt und hoffnung stille zeugen
von erfindungsreichtum
unternehmungsgeist und tatendrang
[Musik]